jojo was geht hier so marx und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video wir
spielen minecraft skywalk in der 1.9
warum schwere der 1.9 ihr habt es
wahrscheinlich schon im titel gelesen
ich werde euch heute einen weg zeigen
wie man in minecraft wendeler ohne hacks
oder sonstwas durch jede x-beliebige
wand durchgehen kann so leute da sind
wir auch schon ab auf dem server und ich
zeig euch einfach wie das geht das
einzige was wir dafür brauchen seht ihr
hier holz wirklich man braucht nichts
anderes als holz dafür und man kann
damit durch jede wand durchgehend ich
werde euch das mal zeigen indem ich
einfach eine wandaufbau ich habe
übrigens cars ausgewählt für die
aufnahme einfach damit ich am ende noch
was zu tun habe und auch ein bisschen
zocken kann ich hoffe mal dass das kein
keine back ups oder sonst was ist aber
ansonsten ich meine 1.9 spiele ich eh
nicht so häufig habe ich jetzt mal nur
für dieses video hier ausgepackt für
euch quasi ihr braucht fünf holz wer von
euch weiß schon was es sein könnte
richtig ein boot sowie wählen ist ganz
einfach mal eine wand aus stein
machen sie ein bisschen platz oder bauen
hier einfach so eine kleine wand hin wo
man normalerweise logischerweise nicht
durchlaufen könnte aber auch um die
gegner kümmern hier nicht wie die runde
okay das war irgendwie nichts schuldig
und ja noch ganz vernünftig spielen
danach ist es so simpel irgendwie ich
wunder mich total ich habe noch kein
einziges video in deutschland dazu
gesehen wie das funktioniert es geht bei
diesem bug ganz einfach darum das boot
dass wir uns gerade gekracht haben vor
der wand richtig zu platzieren
ihr müsst es so nah wie möglich genau so
in etwa mit ihr spazieren dann schiebt
ihr das ein bisschen steigt ein und
manchmal müssen ein bisschen
rumprobieren so leute da seht ihr jetzt
gerade in der wand drin das boot hat
sich reingeschoben dann drückt ihr
einfach einmal shift da seht ihr es
genau ihr müsst das boot so reinschieben
dass es ein bisschen dunkler wird ihr
seht wahrscheinlich den den unterschied
dann klickt die einmal rein und stiftet
und seid auf der anderen seite der wand
okay ich zeig euch nochmal ich baue
jetzt hier müssen wir sie wieder
erkennen einen cobblestone hin
zack einmal durch und da ist der
kommisson und so kommt man durch jede
wand durch ich finde es einfach mega
crazy ich glaube das geht in jeder 1.9
versionen also der server ist auf jeden
fall bis 1.9.2 kompatibel ich weiß nicht
ob dir den bug nicht rausgefunden haben
oder so also wie gesagt er ist kaum
bekannt so auf youtube und so ok also
ich probiere ich das nochmal
ganz kurz zu zeigen es ist halt relativ
schwierig das boot ist verschwunden
nein ist auch vielleicht jeder hat schon
mal gab es relativ schwierig zu
platzieren das boot im singleplayer ist
ein bisschen einfacher aber ihr schiebt
das einfach so hin und dann steigt hier
ein märkte oder wär's gewesen plötzlich
man es einfacher durch schieben kann
fans so wackelt also wenn man es gerade
abbaut
ja genau und dann geht ihr einfach
einmal durch ich glaube das geht sogar
einfacher so auch die leute aber jetzt
muss ich auch mal langsam wieder darum
kümmern
und wir sind auf der innenseite draußen
ja leute so einfach geht das ich zeige
euch das vielleicht einfach noch mal am
ende des videos
aber ja leute so einfach geht das auf
jeden fall meinen beide modus wie dem
des chors ist es ja noch harmlos vor
allerdings so wie ich gerade gemacht hat
da war ja nicht mal jemand anders auf
der insel aber ich meine wenn er
irgendwie wars oder sowas spielt wo am
anfang durch diese schutzmauer
abgetrennt wird
wo leute hingehen dürfen und wo nicht
man kann einfach durch die mauer
durchgehend kennt irgend ein bisschen
server der world auf 1.985 er wollte
dass ich mal mein umfeld betreiber aber
im zweifelsfall wenn ich dafür noch
gebannt ich finde auf jeden fall mega
heftig und total lustig irgendwie die
tatsache dass das so einfach geht und
das ist irgendwie so wenige wissen hoffe
ich jetzt einfach mal nicht dass das
jeder schon weiß aber irgendwie keine
videos dazu auf youtube sind bin ich
voll überraschend ich hab's gefeiert ich
fand's lustig vielleicht ist auch lustig
sagt wenn man das cooles anderes was ihr
euch zeigen konnte also deshalb habe ich
sowieso gefeiert dass sich das video
machen konnte bisher verrückt wurde
tötet mich ja gar nicht übrig minecraft
knowledge hoch 1000 watt für mich
natürlich sage ich euch einfach ja das
ist dass minecraft nach deshalb bringe
ich euch auch gerade so was bei mit
diesem bug der stelle hier noch mal eine
ganz normale welt die nehmen wir einfach
mal wand back erstellen sie warten
generieren dies dass ihr kennt es dir
sind wir auf der die ganz normalen welt
schnappen uns ein bisschen holz mappen
uns ein boot ganz einfach leute ich bin
im creative motto eigentlich ganz egal
welches es ist übrigens das geht mit mit
jeder art von bhutan nehmen wir ein
bisschen bedrock also durch bedrock
behauptet jetzt einfach mal kommt man
normalerweise nicht durch deshalb nicht
einmal game und 0
geben diese eine bedrock kommt hier oben
hin zwar nur hier hin und wir probieren
das ganze noch mal aus weil ich habe
über das gefühl es geht ein bisschen
einfacher eigentlich sogar im
singleplayer durch patrick kommen wir
jetzt wirklich gar nicht durch
normalerweise man muss dabei immer so
ein bisschen rumprobieren dass man das
wirklich tritt ihr könnt wahrscheinlich
schon immer so beim ersten platzieren
sehen so wie gut das boot ist so zum
beispiel geht das natürlich nicht rein
aber es muss schon so beim ersten
platzieren ein bisschen drin sein
und dann ist auch davon auszugehen dass
es ganz rein geht so wie jetzt zum
beispiel dann wird es dunkel und dann
könnt ihr ein shift und seid auf der
anderen seite seht ihr kein blog hier
oben das auf der anderen seite wo es
richtig lustig finde ich keine armen
leute können wir dazu die kommentare
schreiben haye findet ihr das cool
wollt ihr das nochmal sehen falls ich
jemals in meinem leben noch mal
irgendwas gutes finden sollte oder sagt
ihr typ verpiss dich bleibt in einem
boot fahrer herum den ganzen tag ich
weiß nicht wie lange es wieder jetzt
geworden ist ich hoffe mal nicht allzu
kurz und benutzt das natürlich nicht auf
irgendwelchen pvp servern oder sowas
aber mir fällt spontan auch aus the
walls ganz ein womit man sich da
irgendwie ein vorteil bewirken könnte ja
das war es von heute macht es gut und
bis zum nächsten mal